>>> Want to bring back our
political experts for more
analysis on the breaking news
we're following now.
Ron Desantis officially publicly
launching his campaign for
president of the United States
on Twitter.
I understand they've got some
problems over there.
What are you hearing?
>> Yeah, this was a concern some
people had today when they said
they were going to be announcing
this on Twitter spaces, which is
this audio only offer Twitter
has where you can go and list
ton a conversation someone has.
Clearly I'm not sure if they
anticipated how many people
would be listening or trying to
join.
Obviously quite a audience on
this.
There's a lot of glitching that
are delaying this.
It's still difficult to listen
to this.
It's not clear if it's fully
started.
They were trying to do so a few
moments ago.
You heard Elon Musk briefly
speaking on this, but it kept
crashing and dropping.
This is something that was a
potential to happen.
Obviously Twitter has not been
running smoothly as you've seen
how understaffed it's been and
even the Biden campaign has been
mocking it already.
President Biden sending out a
tweet saying this link works.
It's a link to fund raise for
his campaign.
He's already ribbing the
Desantis campaign launch and
just how glitchy it is.
Not off to a smooth start.
This is the concern of course
and this is what when you have
those similar traditional
campaign announcements, you
don't have an issue like this,
but this is how the Desantis
campaign so far is getting
started.
Where they're having not a very
controlled issue and Elon Musk
keeps talking about how many
people are trying to listen.
The expectation is that they
knew it would be a widely
listened to campaign launch and
clearly it's having a lot of
issues.
I don't even think it's
happening.
>> It's very awkward.
It was supposed to start about
20 minutes or so ago.
Hasn't started yet.
Sarah, you're our social media
analyst.
You're an expert in this area.
Give us your analysis of this
major glitch.
>> I was in that audio space and
when I joined, there were about
667,000 people trying to listen.
Twitter has held much bigger
events.
When Elon did his bbc interview
through audio, I think that got
up to 3 million people but what
I think they didn't anticipate
was that many people coming in
at the same time.
Because they said it would start
at 6:00, over a million people
trying to listen to this.
And the problem is that when you
have such a high frequency event
in any kind of technology.
On social media, I'm on my phone
now.
It can be in streaming.
It's the huge amount of people
that often messes this up.
The problem is that he's trying
to send this message that I can
bypass the traditional media.
Go direct to my listeners.
Well, when the first time you
try to do that in launching your
campaign, it doesn't work and
you're almost a half hour late
to your announcement.
>> This is clearly not the
rollout that Desantis and his
campaign were looking for.
Or hoping for, is it?
>> No, it's not.
But I mean, I think we have to
be honest that this outcome
pretty predictable.
The challenge with doing an
event like this and you're
trying to present an image of a
competent campaign that knows
how to put together a smooth
running event, which is a
microcosm of a smooth running
campaign, doing it in this
format introduced a huge amount
of risk.
What's happening now is that
instead of talking about what
Ron Desantis is running on and
how he's running, what his
campaign looks like, people are
going to be talking about how
this event went.
There's such a thing as negative
attention and right now, getting
a lot of negative attention and
it's probably going to continue
and it's probably not going to
be undone by anything that is
said later tonight in a more
traditional format.
First impressions matter a lot
in politics.
I think he is learning a really
important lesson right now that
you know, if you're going to do
something unconventional, you
have to have your ducks in a row
and understand how this is
working and as Sarah was saying,
there are about 600,000 people
in this event.
That's not actually that many
people.
When I checked a couple of
minutes ago, it was about
300,000.
So a lot of people are leaving.
Maybe they're being kicked out
because of technical glitches.
Those are not huge numbers.